في الحرب الحاليه برزت عبوات شواظ التي
صنعتها وطورتها كتائب القسام على مدى
سنوات لتاخذ مكانا بارزا في المعارك
الحاليه نتعرف على مزيد من تفاصيل هذه
العبوات وميزاتها في تقرير لصهيب العصا ثم
نعود الى ان وصلنا الى اخر عبوه وهي عبوه
شواظ قبل 20 عاما ولدت عبوه شواظ هذه
المشاهد تعود الى عام 2005 وقد كانت شواظ
قد دخلت الى الخدمه
حديثا طورتها كتائب القسام من سلسله من
العبوات الناسفه وصولا الى الشكل الحالي
تزن العبوه القساميه 21 كيلوغراما وتخترق
ما بين 60 و65 سنتيمترا من الحديد المصفح
على الاليات العسكريه لكن ابرز ما يميز
شواظ هو طريقه التفجير من مسافه الصفر
لتحقيق اكبر ضرر ممكن بالاليه المستهدفه
يتم الامر بسحب صاعق التفجير وليس عبر
تمديد اسلاك او توصيل اجهزه اخرى اذ كانت
العبوات الاخرى قبل شواظ اشبه ببرميل مفخخ
مشبوك باسلاك وصواعق عن بعد لكن الامر مع
شواظ يعطي المقاتله دقه اكبر وتجنبا
للاخطاء في التمديدات او التشويش على
التوصيلات الكهربائيه هكذا تقوم شواظ
بدورها الكبير لكن ببساطه ان القي المقاتل
قنبله يدويه مع فارق التشبيه والوزن
والقدره التدميريه فقد تم تطوير شواظ
لتعمل بنفس طريقه القنبله اليدويه يسحب
الساع تلقى على الهدف وتنفجر كذلك عبوه
العمل الفدائيه التي تزن 3 كيلوغرامات مع
وجود مغناطيس عليها لتحقيق انفجار في نقطه
معينه في الاليه
المستهدفه اذا هو التشابه في طريقه العمل
البسيطه مع فارق القوه الانفجاريه بين
القنبله اليدويه وعبوه العمل الفدائي
وعبوه الشواف الله اكبر هكذا استطاعت كتاب
القسام ان تطور من القنبله اليدويه
المعروفه عالميا عبوتين من صنعها المحلي
بالاعتماد على نفس اليه التفجير العمل
الفدائي وشواذ لكن ثمه امر لا يصنع في ورش
التصنيع العسكري هو هذا المقاتل الذي يقرر
تنفيذ هذه العمليه اذ يجب وضع هاتين
العبوتين على الاليه مباشره شره لتحقيق
الضرر المطلوب وخلال ثلاث الى اربع ثوان
ستكون قد انفجرت هذا يعني انلا وقت امام
المنفذ للانسحاب من المكان فيعرض نفسه
لخطر الاصابه وربما الاستشهاد اما بشض
العبوه او بالنار المنطلقه منها مثلما هو
الحال في هذه العمليه التي نفذها مقاتل من
قسام في
غزه او هذه العمليه التي نفذها اخر في خان
يونس سريعا قبل ان ي الى النفق كانت
العبوه قد
انفجرت هكذا تدير المقاومه الفلسطينيه
معركتها مع الجيش المتوغلة